Bring sie hoch!
Eigentlichじゃ
Leute, ich sag euch
Ganz den Tag gedönst gemacht
Letzten zwei drei stunden habe ich noch ein bisschen weiter gebastelt an der
streaming webcam
nicht webcam, warum sage ich eigentlich immer webcam, ist das keine webcam streaming software, das ist eine software für überwachungskameras
mit motion detection, warum sage ich immer webcam
die letzten zwei drei stunden weiter gebastelt, ich habe das frontend endlich mal von dieser einen seite so ein paar
unterschiedliche modulen umgewürstet, aber noch nichts was ich gepusht habe. Oh direkt weiß ab, hier der easy killer, das ist ja
schon richtig
Nice dual mit dem friseur, ja ich weiß nicht, an mir soll es nicht liegen
Ja, also wir haben uns überlegt, also ich habe ihn gefragt ob am wochenende er schon was aufnehmen wollen, da hat sich das jetzt so richtig gerührt zu
keine ahnung
Machen wir noch den G-Style 90
Exquisite subscription, dankeschön
Ich muss am freitag noch mal zum zahnarzt, das fällt mir gerade ein, aber da passiert nix
Ich war ja letztens erst, der will mir irgendwas aufschwätzen
Was wir machen sollen unbedingt
Mal gucken was dabei rauskommt
Gut dass du da bist, bei diesen twitch empfehlung, also selfmade ice, ich habe keine ahnung was das für ein link ist, aber das klinge ich schnell an
Ach das ist ach das ist jetzt kenne ich das auch
Was ist das für ein streben
Warum nicht
War das gerade empfehlung bei mir oder was ist das für ein streben
Was ist das für ein streben
Na ja warum nicht
War das gerade empfehlung bei mir oder was, das ist ja geil
Das ist eine geile empfehlung
Solange wupplos offline ist die welle kann er bis vor ad hd alles klar, na ja warum nicht
Vape nation
Was ist das für ein streben
Aber sowas von
Die streben empfehlung teilweise merkwürdig, wobei ganz ehrlich
Wenn es nach mir geht dürfte es das legal zu kaufen geben aber es geht ja nicht nach mir
Ich wie gesagt nicht heute heute ich ich sag ja sonst immer ich sag ja sonst immer kurzer streben ja aber heute wirklich kurzer streben
Bringst sich mal aufgefallen dass die firefox bedienung dass die die firefox bedienung jede version
irgendwie schlechter machen
So zum beispiel wir machen jetzt mal keine ahnung wir machen jetzt mal hier irgendwie geiles halt so ja ja ist gut firefox so und wenn ich jetzt
Also vielleicht vielleicht versteht das jemand von euch hat mehr big brain und hat es kapiert und ich habe es einfach nicht gechecked
Aber wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise meine history angucken will da muss ich entweder sowas hier machen
Oder oder noch schlimmer ich muss das hier machen
Was ist das denn weil kann ich nicht noch englische shortcut aber
Wo ist denn bei firefox die history ansicht hin diese fullscreen history ansicht wüsst ihr denn hin
Ach hier unten
Aber
Guck mal also gerade diese komischen menus ich weiß nicht was mit ihnen los ist früher hatten die ganz stinknormale menus
Die konntest du bedienen ohne laufen klicken zu müssen die konntest du schneller bedienen die sind doch gleich aufgegangen
Und jetzt haben sie dieses komische gefunden hier an der rechten seite
Das ist das ist total aber nicht
Das haben die wahrscheinlich gemacht dass es mehr tablet like ist aber es interessiert mich ob das doch browser ob das tablet like ist
Ja steuerung ha geht aber trotzdem die also die bedienung wird wirklich
total abartig
Ich habe echt das gefühl dass google die bezahlt dafür dass firefox schlecht sein muss ich mein firefox verdient glaube ich tatsächlich an google
noch am meisten weil die immer noch startseite und sowas haben aber
Trotzdem die bedienung ist mittlerweile wirklich wirklich haare sträumt übrigens diese menus haben zum glück immer noch kann sich noch einer an
die
firefox 38 oder sowas verinnern
So was hier
Doch
Das das konnte man auch das konnte man irgendwie noch bedienen ja das hier ist das moment das 38 ist mit diesem menü wo es
Eingeführt haben ne dann meine ich das nicht
Das ist wieder ein ganz anderes menü ach was weiß ich ich muss euch sagen firefox hat es bei mir eh ein bisschen verschissen
weil die haben mit firefox 68
Knallbusch das ist ein guter einwand
Ich habe firefox wir machen jetzt firefox schwanzvergleicht oder irgendwie sowas keine ahnung worauf das rauslaufen soll ich habe firefox schon
Da hieß es noch firebird browser
Das ist ein ganz anderes menu
das weiß kaum noch einer
firefox hieß ursprünglich firebird browser
Und die mussten sich dann unbedingt wahrscheinlich weniger datenbank oder sowas
Richtig boomer überlegt man das war guck mal mal history
Guck mal mal history die haben noch irgendwie so eine version history
Oh
Wotter wotter fack ach guck mal die haben sogar verschiedene versionen hier drin
Dann haben sie versucht teilweise eigene mobile operating hier firebird
Ja
Was ganz am anfang war die version history
Version ach hier die haben sowas eigenes
Hier early versions
Genau ich habe ich habe das nämlich schon verwendet seit das firebird browser hieß
Weiß aber nicht was das für eine hier firebird ja so nur irgendwie sowas hier in der richtung glaube ich irgendwie sowas hier
Und das damals war kam man sich extrem hacker mans vor
Wenn man das verwendet hat weil ihr wisst ja was die ganzen noobs verwendet haben die haben alle
Internet explorer verwendet in i6 und wahrscheinlich sogar
Was waren 2013 für eine
Was waren 2000 2003 für eine internet explorer version angesagt
Zeitschmeyer
Versions Versions 6 ja
Die 6 war angesagt
Die 6 ja kein wunder ja kein wunder dass man damals sich wie der krasse heckermann vorkam mit firefox
6 ist ja nur wirklich ich mein das hier was hier drauf ist das ist ja immerhin schon 11
So aber i6 ist der kacke browser
Wenn zwar ernsthaft boomer boomer intensiv files aber mal hier
Aller geste mehr fort
Das tut ja wehe
Worum geht es gerade ich habe gesagt es hat jemand im chat geschrieben er benutzt firefox seit version 2
Da habe ich gesagt ich verwende firefox schon seit es
Firebird browser hieß und es war damals die alternative zu i6
Ja ja so sah das aus ganz ganz grausam ganz grausam das ding
Ja
Was überlegen dass es 2003 also gewesen ist da war eben noch xp noch halbwegs neu
Ja irgendwann haben die sich umbenannt und dann war es firefox und ich habe ich habe firefox ich habe es ewig verwendet ja
bis frage ich nicht bis irgendwie
noch ganz lang als haupt browser bis die irgendwann
mal angefangen haben
folgendes zu machen die haben die version 68 rausgebracht
Und das war für den arsch weil mit version 68 haben die alle addons kaputt gemacht
Und vielleicht bringen es auch durcheinander durcheinander war das 68
Ich benutze definitiv schon länger chrome als 2019 vielleicht war das auch 60
Vielleicht war noch 60 vielleicht bringt auch 58 oder so durcheinander
58 oder so durcheinander
Hier legacy addons ja hier firefox 57 58 war es
Dort haben die die dort hier 57 dort haben die quasi alle alle addons und getürntes eingestellt
Das hat dazu geführt da war genau da war no script mit mittlerweile geht es wieder halbwegs aber no script war nie
mehr das gleiche ja also das war die zeit so und dann habe ich mir gedacht ok
Also ich habe jetzt die ausfall zwischen dem firefox und nicht funktioniert im no script oder ich nehme chrome mit irgendeinem adblock oder so
Da bin ich da haben sie es verkackt 2017 so im dreh da haben sie es verkackt das war quantum genau das war das wo ich dann gesagt
Okay, dann nehme ich halt chrome weil
Meiner ansicht nach ist es so dass firefox also der große vorteil von firefox eigentlich ist dass es so zumindest mal ursprünglich so
von hackermans für hackermans war
Und chrome war halt schon immer so der google
Von polished will ich jetzt nicht sprechen bei google
Der google für die die masse gedachte geschichte das war mir von anfang an klar ehrlich gesagt dass chrome also
Seit dem start und seit es nicht zu den instant google rip wurde wie stadia
Weil mir klar chrome geht ab das war schon direkt abzusehen nach den ersten zwei jahren so und
Ich habe ich habe ich habe nie chrome verwendet immer firefox verwendet ich habe überhaupt keinen grund gesehen dafür chrome zu verwenden
Und dann so um diese zeit hier rum auch schon auch schon hier ganz am anfang dann hat firefox angefangen immer merkwürdige dinger zu immer
Merkwürdige dinger zu machen die haben gesagt ok wir machen
Irgendwie drei verschiedene mobile browser add-ons auf auf android nicht mal richtig wir machen
legacy add-ons kommen weg
Thunderbird wird outsourced wird nicht mehr irgendwie
Richtig offiziell bei uns mit dabei entwickelt weiß ich nicht was sie da getrieben haben
Ab 2014 wurden die cringe ja das deckt sich so ungefähr auch mit meinen
Erfahrungen so und da wurde halt aus dem echt guten hacker hacker man browser mit firefox
Wurde so ein so ein so ein ding was nicht weiß was es will will will sich firefox jetzt an profis
Also was heißt profis an an technik interessierte richten oder nicht
Wollen sie jetzt eine tablet version machen oder nicht man muss das aber firefox auf android ist ja auch so ein ding
Also richtig funktioniert der einzige grund warum ich firefox verwendet auf meinem android tablet ist
Weil meine kameras nur im firefox funktionieren weil chrome auf dem fire hd nicht richtig tut mit den
Mit den streams von den kameras so und selbst das haben sie verkackt weil firefox den decoder rausgeschmissen hat
Ja und da kam noch dazu genau was kussi sagt so ist es dass sie irgendwie den fokus nicht auf das gelegt haben was das sein sollte
nämlich
performance und
Konfigurierbarkeit add-on auswahl und sonstige geschichten was halt firefox ausgemacht haben
Vor allem kass kass ganz ehrlich ich nehme auch firefox ein bisschen weniger schnell als chrome wenn er gut
customizable ist wenn er gescheite plug ins hat und wenn ich wenn es für mich der angenehmere browser ist
so und
mittlerweile es gibt ein paar sachen die firefox immer noch besser machen wie
Ja das ist richtig ich habe ich habe auch einen da aber ich habe noch nicht ausprobiert es gibt es es gibt ein paar sachen
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen genau gibt ein paar sachen ich immer noch besser finde bei firefox
Warum habe ich denn eigentlich eine fritz box?
Warum habe ich fritz box 68 bin ich da hängen geblieben
Es gibt ein paar sachen im firefox die ich immer noch besser finde
Als im chrome und eines davon ist die leiste hier oben
Weil chrome sucht standardmäßig nur
In den letzten in den letzten seiten in den letzten paar seiten historien die du aufhattest oder die du besonders oft frequentierst
firefox hat
Eine richtige history bookmark favorite volltext suche eingebaut in der leiste das hat chrome nicht das finde ich viel viel besser
Ja lasst mal überlegen was gibt es sonst noch
Kleinen bursch ja genau im prinzip ist die adress leiste ist das was es bei mir auch ausmacht
Es gab auch noch die die entwickler tools finde ich besser als bei als bei chrome
So und lasst mal überlegen was was gefällt mir beim firefox noch besser als beim chrome gut man davon abgesehen
Er ist nicht von google was auch ein vorteil ist
Was gefällt mir dann noch besser beim firefox als bei google add-ons ist ja mittlerweile fast egal
Und firefox macht auch so ein bisschen die google taktik dann erst erst
Releasen sie irgendwelche link services oder irgendwelche sachen dann dann stellen sie sie wieder ein
Dann machen sie sync sachen dann stellen sie wieder ein und ganz komische dinge
Ja
Ach ja ich finde auch noch eine weitere sache gut beim firefox und zwar ist das dass man proxy settings hat
richtig echte proxy settings
Die hat man nämlich beim chrome gar nicht mehr
Genau firefox send was
Hat man die unter windows auch nicht oder linux hat man die auf jeden fall nicht mehr
Proxy genau
Open your computers proxy settings man hat keine extra proxy settings haben kann die system proxy settings verwenden
Das finde ich auch noch besser an firefox aber ansonsten
Ist halt nicht mehr viel übrig von dem was mir an firefox so gut gefallen hat ich finde das menü auch mittlerweile total umständlich und kompliziert
Ich habe ich habe jeden eindruck firefox gibt ihre kohle hauptsächlich für ihren ceo aus
Und um werbung auf auf twitter zu machen dass das internet fucked ist kriegt ihr die werbung auf twitter auch von mozilla
2020 und das internet sind fucked
Also fuckt kriegt ihr die auch die werbung die ist richtig dumm
2020 im internet sind fucked
2020 im internet sind fucked ich weiß überhaupt nicht was die mir sagen wollen damit
Mozilla ich habe keine ahnung also also ich glaube werbung wo ein wo man einfach nur verwirrt ist
Ist ziemlich schlechte werbung
Soll er werbung nicht irgendwas sagen
irgendwas irgendwas
Irgendetwas mit einem machen mich verwirrt die firefox werbung einfach nur hier guckt ich mal in die hier
twitter firefox aber ich kann jetzt nicht fucked suchen 2020
Ja gut wie kriegen wir das wie kriegen wir das raus
Ja
Ja add
Ach keine ahnung aber ihr kennt die werbung wahrscheinlich anfuck die internet genau die werbung meine ich ja
fire twitter firefox
Anfuck internet genau den meine ich
Ich genau ich finde das so fehl diese werbung genau das hier das hier das ist so das ist so fehl so eine dumme werbung
Alter
Was haben 2020 als internet beide sind fucked
Aber aufgeben geht auch nicht für sie das ist so richtig bescheuert was soll mir diese werbung überhaupt sagen ich fange doch bestimmt nicht damit an dass ich jetzt
anfuckt anfuckt werde
Anfucked sind wir als informatiker schon oft genug warum soll ich denn jetzt auch anfuckt
Im browser werden was ist das verstehe ich kann es leuchten wir nicht ein
Gatschi was
Nee
Keine ahnung firefox logik naja gut also ich bin heute nicht lange und
Schauen wir mal was was gucken wir uns denn was kommt uns an hier das da das habe ich mir schon seit zwei tagen auf dem tablet
gespeichert ich bin noch nicht dazu gekommen mir das anzugucken
der titel
Sieht so aus als ist das video entweder der übelste reinfall und einfach nur sinnloser clickbait oder es ist cool
Ich habe keine ahnung muss man es mal angucken
Smoritz alles klar
Hoffentlich hoffentlich schreit jetzt nicht gleich los
Hallo was geht hier ist wieder das moritz am stag ane das ist ja englisch anscheinend habe ich vergessen
Wobei die sagen immer gerne wassup die schreien dann immer übelst los das sind die ganzen reaction youtube leute
Früher was macht eigentlich wisst ihr was mir gerade einfällt was macht eigentlich herr tutorial
Was macht eigentlich gibt es den noch
Frag mich nicht erste was wir finden ist herr tutorial schwul ja was macht eigentlich herr tutorial gibt es den noch
Okay, den gibt es noch die wahrheit wieso ich nie studiert habe
Okay, ich wollte jetzt was blödes sagen aber
Doof kann er nicht sein weil er hat damit sicherlich einige kohle gemacht
Wie ich sechs einkommensquelle habe okay
Dreckskonnen ja da war der ist der ist länger auf youtube als ich und ich bin auch schon zehn jahre da
Wie findest du distro tube auf youtube von dem habe ich glaube ich schon die ein oder anderen sachen gesehen die war ganz gut
Bin mir nicht mehr sicher wer das genauer so ein lila logo ja das war ganz okay das war ganz okay
So also wir gucken jetzt mal die wish festblätter an
Wobei der hört sich gar nicht so kokona an was ist denn das für ein akzent
Was ist denn das für ein akzent
Das ist ja ein akzent
Australien
Die sind doch billig auf mich ich meine da kriege ich für fünf euren und zwei terabyte usb stick
Diese anzeige schon wieder
Okay gst wenn wir rausbekommen was gst für eine steuer ist gsd tax india
Australien okay der typ kommt aus australien oder aus kanada entweder kommt er aus australien oder aus kanada
Diese anzeige schon wieder ultra fast file transfer super speed acht terabyte
Da weißt du weißt du schon wieder bescheid dass das scam ist und guck mal dieses high quality usb kabel dabei
Ach du hast das schon gesehen stamina x ich habe das seit ein paar tagen im tablet gespeichert
Und ich wollte es mir die ganze zeit schon mal angucken kriege ich die ganzen tage schon empfohlen
Das ist so ein typischer china shop überschrift so eine tür das ist das eins zu eins so steht das auch auf aliexpress
Die schreiben immer möglichst viel in den titel rein wahrscheinlich dass in der suchmaschine besser gefunden werden
Manchmal stehen da manchmal stehen da auch dinge drinne die gar nicht stimmen
Zum beispiel wenn man sich controller oder technik kram kauft dann stehen da oftmals hersteller drin von denen das gar nicht ist
Und weil die leute halt nach diesen herstellern suchen und so was und dann ist es halt gar nicht von denen
Und meint ja auch das sind wirklich echte acht terabyte ja
Und wie viel hat es gekostet 55 euro für 50 euro kriegst ja nicht mal eine normale magnet acht terabyte platte
Die ganze
das gar nicht ist
und weil die Leute halt nach diesen Herstellern suchen und sowas und dann
dann ist es halt gar nicht von denen
und meint ihr auch das sind wirklich echte 8TB ja
wie viel hat es gekostet? 55 Euro
für 55 Euro kriegst du ja noch nicht mal eine normale Magnet 8TB Platte
I'm not happy
auch wenn Frank wüsste dass die Probleme liegen noch viel tiefer mit Sicherheit
aber wisst ihr was mich schon mal sehr stutzig macht bei der ganzen Geschichte
wenn die schreiben 12, 2 oder 4
das ist ein bisschen komische
bisschen komische Staffelung
mannerweise hast du noch ein G dabei
äh noch ein T dabei
komisch mal gucken
ja Florian das kann kann schon mal Verluste gibt's immer
aber du kannst dich bei Aliexpress melden dann kriegst du das Geld wieder
Moment was hatte der da eben?
achso ah Preise Preise für
für das ok 50 Euro
Hauptsache die Rakete ist neben dran
ist klar ist klar garantiert garantiert schafft die das
wenn wir Glück haben schafft die 30 MB die Sekunde wenn es hochkommt
habt ihr das gesehen?
Moment habt ihr das gesehen?
wartet mal wartet mal
da steht 8TB und da unten steht 1860G
was ist das für eine Logik
ok weiter
ich auch nicht
was ist ein Kari-El
das ist ein typischer Shina-Karri-El
Moment Moment Moment Moment
warum ist das eine SSD die 5400 Umdrehungen hat
ist verdächtig verdächtig
ja das hab ich auch grad gedacht
naja Stomina X weil Wish selbst ja nix macht
Wish selbst vermittelt ja nur die Sachen deswegen ich sag's immer wieder
Wish ist der größte Kacknoob Shop
die gescheiten Leute bestellen direkt in China das was sie brauchen
und die Noobs bestellen Amazon und so die Kacknoobs die sich schlau fühlen
die bestellen bei Wish
alles klar
das ist ein CPU oder?
ja das soll glaub ich ein CPU sein
aber warum ist da ein Glas über das CPU
vor allem High Highly Sophisticated Photoshop Skills USB 3.0
ah
Er arbeitet mit usb 3.0 und usb 2.0, um schnellere Transferspiele zu erzeugen und dann grafft er, um alles zu zeigen.
Mit Pan Xing da, für irgendeine Grunde.
Dann bekommen wir eine Foto von dem, was wir jetzt machen.
Und dann eine Foto von dem, was wir machen.
Was explodiert, Alter? Warum explodiert es da unten?
Weißt du, du hast eine Mütze bestellt im November bei Wish, die kam im Mai.
Wirklich, ich hab noch nie was bei Wish bestellt.
Oh hier, Big Brain Technik Logo.
Ich seh überhaupt keinen Sinn, nicht da drin in Wish.
Was du ein bisschen außer Just for Fun machst, weil man sich drüber lustig machen will.
Alles klar.
Sollte es nicht 8G sein?
Ich brauch auch so eine Unterlage.
Meine blaue Silikonunterlage ist da nicht gut genug, um Videos zu machen.
Ich brauch auch so eine Big Brain Unterlage.
Müssen wir gleich mal bei Amazon gucken.
Was ist das hier?
Lötenunterlage oder sowas?
Wie heißt denn sowas?
Antistatikunterlage oder sowas.
So was brauchen wir.
Ohle eine von Linux Techno.
Antistatikmatte?
Sowas da.
Arbeitsunterlage.
Auf die Idee wär ich jetzt nicht gekommen, das ist viel zu einfach.
Ah, ja sowas hier.
Genau.
Sowas hier.
Ok, jetzt gucken wir erstmal fertig.
Also zeig her das Ding.
Auf gehts.
Jetzt kommt's.
Ja das ist normal.
Das ist teilweise normal bei so China-Dingern, dass die jetzt nicht sonderlich exquisite verpackt sind.
Ich hab schon mal ein Paket bekommen, das hat ein Loch.
Aber so die komplette Seite, ein Loch gehabt.
Da hat quasi einfach eine Seite von der Box gefehlt.
Die war einfach raus.
Das haben wir uns hier sogar im Stream angeguckt.
Das war wo ich diese USB-Schalter da bestellt hab.
Also die Dinger da.
Wo man USB-Geräte an- und ausschalten kann.
Da war einfach ein Loch im Paket.
Da war einfach die eine Seite komplett weg.
Aber es ist nichts passiert, weil das ganze war innen drin noch mal eingepackt.
Und hing da irgendwie drinne fest und es ist nichts passiert.
Da hab ich schon gut geguckt, dass das Ding einfach offen war.
Stabina, schauen wir mal.
Oh, what?
Moment, war das Sound bei ihm oder bei mir?
Ich hab sie...
Ah, FGarrett27Fewer haust mich. Dankeschön für den Host.
Ich hab's gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Was ist das für ein Sound?
Normalerweise hab ich links auf dem zweiten Monitor so eine Vorschau, wo ich das sehe.
Aber, äh, ja.
Das wurde nicht angezeigt.
So, zeig mal hier.
Leichen Sack, ja.
Sieht wirklich ein bisschen so aus.
Ich find's ja schon mal cool, was die für einen super stabilen Gummi hier drum gemacht haben,
dass es nicht auseinanderfällt.
Oha, was ist das?
Ich hab bei Wish eine 8TB SSD bestellt.
Mal gucken, was rauskommt.
Was mich stutzig macht, ist, dass da angeblich irgendwelche Süßigkeiten dabei sind.
Warum kriegt man random Süßigkeiten dabei, wenn man bei Wish eine SSD bestellt?
Da ist doch was im Pusch.
Und ich würd es definitiv nicht essen.
Dankeschön, F-Garage.
Paulgars Host.
Was?
Das sieht aus wie eine Bluttransfusion.
Okay, Chat jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Jetzt mal ernst gemeinte Frage.
Wenn ihr bei Wish eine SSD bestellt und ihr bekommt so eine Bluttransfusion,
die für Halloween ist.
Okay.
Würdet ihr daraus was trinken?
Ich auch nicht.
Wer weiß, was du da alles trinkst.
Was sich aus dem Plastik dann für...
Na Feinstaub wird es nicht sein,
aber für krebserregendes Zeugs löst.
Das willst du wahrscheinlich nie im Leben haben.
Ich hab gestern...
Hab ich auch schon wieder dran gedacht,
dass man überhaupt nicht...
Manchmal müsste man besser aufpassen.
So muss ich erzählen.
Ich hab mir für 3D-Trucke so was gekauft.
Das sind Schrauben.
Was heißt Schrauben? Gewinde.
Die kann man mit einem Lötkolben in Plastik reinschmelzen.
Also sprich, du hältst da vorne ein Lötkolben rein
und dann schmilzt du es in Plastik rein.
Und wenn das Plastik dann kalt wird, ist das echt bombenfest.
Das ist gedacht für 3D-Trucker-Zeug.
Ich hab das auch letztens...
Also gestern...
Ist ja auch egal. Ich hab ein paar geschlossene Fenster gemacht
und hab vier solche Dinger in 3D-Truck reingeschweißt.
Reingeschmolzen.
Und während ich da so sitze,
so voll mit der Nase über dem Zeug und das einatme
und ich mir so unterbewusst denke irgendwie,
na, so schlecht riecht das gar nicht.
Und dann ist mir irgendwie so nach 5 Minuten eingefallen,
Alter, mach mal das Fenster auf und versuch das mal nicht unbedingt hier direkt einzuatmen alles.
Ich hab 5 Minuten quasi irgendwelche komischen
3D-Trucker-Plastik-Abgase beim Reinsp...
Dingsen da inhaliert.
Ich mein, man muss ja
sich nicht mehr geben als notwendig.
Ja, und so sieht das dann am Ende aus.
Das funktioniert aber wirklich gut.
Für Gift-Doors, ja. Okay, PLA, habe ich mir sagen lassen,
ist nicht so giftig. Das ist so das Standardzeug beim 3D-Trucker.
Das funktioniert echt extrem gut. Ich hab's gestern das erste Mal
richtig ausprobiert an einem selbst getruckten Gehäuse.
Du schmilzt die Dinger mit einem Lötkolben da rein
und das ist bombenfest danach. Du kannst richtig
gute, normale Schrauben nehmen und das ist einfach
fest. Also das lohnt sich, die Dinger.
Bloß einatmen sollte man's nicht. So, jetzt erstmal hier fertig gucken.
Brauchen wir ewig.
What the?
Oh nein, er will das nicht trinken, oder?
Alter, trinkt das doch nicht.
Oh, der trinkt da wirklich was draus. Warum?
Nodaz ist raus.
Warum trinkt man da raus?
Okay, wenn es purer Wodka ist, das er noch reingemacht hat,
ja, dann tötet das ab. Aber trotzdem, es gibt genug
Materialien, da füllst du was rein
und das löst sich dann erst nach einer Zeit aus dem Plastik raus.
Also das würde ich mir...
Okay, weiter.
Du musst mir die SSD angucken.
Oh, hochwertige Verpackung.
Das ist...
Ach so, C, Y,
8TB, 8T,
AJAJA, AJAJA, G, 8TB,
AJAJA, ATA, alles klar.
Das ist quasi ein S, also
SATA wahrscheinlich.
QR-Code scannen, okay, Moment.
Leute, ich scanne den QR-Code, ich gucke mal, wo ich rauskomme.
Ich traue mich nicht, den QR-Code zu scannen von Wish.
Soll ich den QR-Code scannen?
Kennt jemand eine Desktop-Scanner-App?
Mal ohne Mist. Gibt es sowas?
Gibt es sowas? So einen Screenshot,
QR-Code-Screenshot-Dingser für den Desktop?
Sowas muss es doch geben, ist doch viel spannender, als wenn ich das mit dem Handy mache.
Das muss ich grad mal suchen.
GitHub-QR-Code-Scanner-Windows.
Code 2 kenne ich nicht.
Was ist das? Nee.
Chrome-Extension.
QR-Code-Chrome.
QR-Code-Extension, QR-Code-Extension.
Macht was?
QR-Code-Extension, ermöglicht ein QR-Code für die Akte... Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Kann ShareX das? Echt?
Ich rede hier übrigens von ShareX und nicht von X-Share.
Öffne das lieber in der Linux-Kiste.
Ja, da kann ich ja mit ShareX nicht machen.
Okay, das kann QR-Code lesen.
So was gibt's... Okay, okay, okay.
Muss es doch eine Browser-Extension geben.
Da mach ich's nämlich unter Linux.
Chrome-Read-QR-Code-Extension.
Da muss es doch irgendwas geben.
QR-Code-Reader.
By-By-Chen-Ding-Long-Death.
Ah ja, hier. Okay.
Click-Extension-I-Can-Use-To-Read-On-Current-Tab.
Okay, das brauchen wir jetzt.
Exzellent, ich mach die VM an.
Ich trau mich nicht, das unter Windows aufzumachen.
Wer weiß, wo wir da rauskommen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es nur die China-Seite selbst.
Also, 813.
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Ich muss gucken, wo wir da rauskommen.
Also, 813.
Alter YouTube, nicht nerven.
Okay, QR-Code-Reader-Chrome-Extension.
Wobei, das ist Firefox, das ist gar kein Chrome.
Das ist Chrome, gut.
Exzellent.
Etto-Chrome, zack.
Gut.
So, dann schauen wir uns das Ganze...
Dann schauen wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Ihr seht, ich verwende Chrome hier nie.
Ich hab sogar keinen Adblocker drinne.
Setup gibt's nicht.
Es gibt Ausrufezeichen Linux, glaube ich, und Ausrufezeichen...
Wenn ich meine Kommandos wüsste.
Okay, also, QR-Code-Reader.
What the...
Oh Gott, warum ist das alles immer so ein Crap und funktioniert nicht?
Da ist doch ein QR-Code.
Warum kann ich das nicht screenshoten oder so?
Gebated.
Es muss doch die Möglichkeit geben...
Das lässt mir jetzt keine Ruhe.
Es muss doch die Möglichkeit geben, mit Chrome ein QR-Code zu scannen.
Queen Elsa, ja, das brauch ich jetzt.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Jetzt kriege ich schon irgendwelche Bibel-Ersatz-Dinger empfohlen.
Ich will QR-Codes.
Stand da nicht was von der Tastenkombination?
Click-Extension-Icon, nee, nee.
Ja, es wundert mich echt, dass es sowas nicht gibt.
Das wundert mich echt.
Chrome-QR-Code-Reader.
Das muss es doch geben, warum...
Das wundert mich extrem, dass es sowas nicht gibt.
Das hatten wir schon.
Mit bloßen Augen.
Was ist das?
Der QR-Code-Reader und Generator.
Das klingt auch schon super vertra...
Oh, super vertrauenserweckend, diese Extension.
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ich installiere jetzt eine chinesische Extension.
Oh, guck mal, ist das ein QR-Helper.
QR-Code-Extension.
Simple, quick.
Aha. Aha.
Okay, okay, was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Das hatten wir gerade schon.
Auch irgendeine Mist, die man nicht braucht.
Und dann haben wir noch die...
Okay, es ist schwieriger als gedacht.
Ach, rechtsklick.
Okay, und jetzt?
Ich will nicht generaten.
Ich will es lesen.
Ist das geil, wie kompliziert das ist.
Wahnsinn.
Mach Screenshot, ja, und dann?
Und dann?
Ja, mit ShareX, aber ich will es unter Linux machen.
Da muss es noch eine Browser-Erweiterung geben.
Natürlich kann ich das machen.
Ach, so einen Screenshot.
Ich habe noch nicht mal ein Screenshot-Tool installiert.
Okay, das ist eine gute Idee, das machen wir jetzt.
Der XFCE-Screenshotter, den brauchen wir jetzt.
Okay, gut zu wissen, was da drin steht, aber ich will das jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Kann doch nicht sein, select region, okay.
Oh, hier, zack, QR-Code.
Made in China.
Save.
Ja, in Download speichern wir das Ganze.
Screenshot.
Hallo?
Wie öffnet man da jetzt hier was?
Aber warum steht das nicht in Download?
Ja, hat das jetzt einen Öffnenknopf?
Max komplett lost wieder.
Hat Chrome einen Öffnenknopf?
Ich meine, ich kann das reintrecken und droppen.
Das funktioniert.
Ha, exellent.
Scan QR-Code.
Okay, leck mich.
Das wird zu dumm.
Okay, ich probier jetzt noch mal den anderen, ich probier jetzt noch mal den anderen.
Pass mal auf, noch den anderen.
What the fuck?
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass ich der einzige will, der QR-Code von, okay, okay.
Gute Frage.
Was soll ich machen?
Code to QR-Code Desktop Reader.
Ja, das gibt's aber wahrscheinlich nicht für Windows.
Okay, QR-Code.
Was gibt's für Unterlegungsprogramme für QR-Code?
QTQR, alles klar.
Das brauchen wir jetzt.
Ups, ich geb dir jetzt keine Ruhe.
Das muss jetzt sein.
QTQR.
Oh, sieht ja exquisite, high-end aus, dieses Programm.
Downloads Screenshot.
Ha, wir haben's decoded.
QtQR hat uns gerettet.
Excellent, also in dem QR-Code steht CY8TB.
Okay, das war essentiell zu decoden.
Was passiert, wenn man Edit drückt?
Ganz wichtig, ganz wichtig, dass wir das jetzt gewusst haben.
Und vor allem, warum steht das Gleiche noch mal da drauf?
Das ist wahrscheinlich, dass es beim wahren Ausgang scannen können oder so.
Gut.
Also, auf geht's.
Ich meine, der Formfaktor kommt ungefähr hin.
Great, but that's it. No instructions, no nothing. And this is the brand Huawei, by the way, which as you can see there, there's Huawei written there.
So we use the bundled cable and the case is now out of its plastic wrap.
Now, when you connect an external hard drive up to a computer, you can usually hear the drives.
Now, I'm going to hold the drive up to the microphone so that you can hear it.
Also, a quick jump cut, that information that I just said then is only for hard drives that have actual mechanical parts.
And solid state drives do not have any moving parts in them, so if you were to connect it to a computer, you wouldn't hear anything anyways.
Alright, and we are...
Ich habe noch nie, das ist echt eine gute Idee, das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Ich habe noch nie eine Chrome-Extension programmiert.
Schrome, QR-Code-Reader.
Ich habe noch nie eine Chrome-Extension programmiert, keine Ahnung, wie das geht.
Im Zweifelsfall ist das irgendetwas Java-Script crap.
Was jetzt?
Ah, er hat es erkannt.
Und okay, okay, also das ist schon mal merkwürdig, dass sich das als vier verschiedene Partitionen meldet.
Jetzt müssen wir mal noch ausprobieren, was passiert, wenn man einen Rate da drüber macht.
Da gleich noch ein Rate Null drüber.
Danach wird Steam streamen, ja.
Ist das noch Windows 7? Nee, oder?
Weil das hier sieht so oldschool aus, am Ende, das ist schon Windows 10.
Finde gut, dass er PC-Crap auf dem Desktop hat.
Mal gucken, wie lange er schreibt.
Also ich denke mal, spätestens 5G ist vorbei.
Oh, Highspeed.
Haben die nicht was von 130 MB geschrieben?
Er liest mich.
Die liest mich, kommt hier nicht von diesem, von irgendeinem, wahrscheinlich von dem Testtool hier, oder?
H2-Test-W, ist das nicht von der CT das?
H2-Test-W?
Nee, das nicht, das ist von...
Doch!
Das wird das sein!
Ich wusste, es kam mir gerade übelst bekannt vor, dass ich das schon mal gesehen habe.
Das wird wahrscheinlich die README sein, von dem Ding.
Ich meine, das ist schon oldschool, die Datei liest mich TXT zu nennen in 2020.
Oh, was jetzt?
What is happening?
Dann ist es eine Festplatte, ja?
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst, wer testet heute noch irgendwelche Festplatten anhand von einem Geräusch?
Zumal es auch gar nicht so ohne ist, wenn du da was hast, was dann mit 7000 oder 7200 Umdrehungen spinnt,
die Dinger hin und her zu kippen im laufenden Betrieb ist nicht so angenehm für die.
Früher hat man immer gesagt, man darf die Festplatte nicht kopfüber machen.
Okay, aber die ist schon mal ultra lahm mit 10,5.
Okay, alle haben das Video schon gesehen.
Zeigst du uns auch?
Was ist das?
Ist das ein USB-Stick-Rate oder was haben die da gemacht?
Nee, noch nicht mal, das ist ja kein Raid.
Ein USB-Stick-Bundle oder was?
Chinese Engineering.
Und vor allem, dass das noch in so einer komischen Tüte drin steckt.
Na, wahrscheinlich, dass es keinen Kurzschluss auf der Metall-Rückseite kriegt.
Das ist ein USB-Hub.
Vor allem, wo kommt dieses USB-Kabel hierher?
Wo gehört dieses USB-Kabel?
Da normalerweise dran, kommt das da raus und dann schließt man es dran an oder?
Das ist vom USB-Hub, das liegt einfach nur da drin.
Ist schon fail, ist schon fail das Ding.
Was ist das für eine ranzige Tüte da drin?
Boah, das ist ja kaputt ohne Ende.
Guck mal hier, wie viel Heißkleber.
Aber anders hält dieser Kack nicht zusammen.
Stimmt, Niko Rock, du hast recht, die Tüte ist da drin, dass es nicht rumwackelt.
Für irgendwelche Schaumstoff-Dinger hatten die kein Geld.
So eine Plastiktüte kommt da einfach rein.
Überleg mal, für 50 Dollar kriegst du schon eine Terabyte SSD?
Du kriegst auf jeden Fall im Angebot nur 512.
Aber eine 512er kriegst du.
Genau, guck mal, er hätte eine echte 512G SSD für den Preis haben können.
Moment, ist das?
Nee, das sind keine Micro SD Karten.
Ich habe für eine Sekunde gedacht, das wäre Micro SD auf USB und dann in einem USB-Hub.
Aber ist es nicht.
Es ist ein USB-Stick ohne Hülle.
Mit wahrscheinlich dem absolut besten Flash-Speicher, den man so findet.
Das erklärt auch die vier Partitionen.
Die geben sich übrigens noch nicht mal Mühe, das hier irgendwie zusammen zu machen.
Das ist einfach ein USB-Hub, der mit dem Kabel durchgereicht wird.
Der meldet sich dann auch am Rechner.
Das sind einfach halt vier unterschiedliche USB-Sticks.
StaminaX, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Gut.
Nee, das ist auf keinen Fall.
Das sind doch im Leben keine 2TB USB-Sticks.
Das sind vielleicht 16G oder 32G oder sowas.
Aber das werden mit Sicherheit keine 2TB USB-Sticks.
Gibt es überhaupt 2TB USB-Sticks?
Ja, muss es geben.
Es gibt 2TB Micro SD.
Die sind ultra teuer.
Arkenas, weil das ein Marketplace ist.
Im Prinzip ist Wish der verlängerte Arm von China-Shops.
Also Leute bestellen auf Wish, die geben die Adresse weiter an den China-Hersteller.
Und der China-Hersteller schickt es direkt zum Kunde.
Und die Seller auf Wish haben damit gar nichts zu tun.
Deswegen sage ich ja immer,
Wish ist der China-Shop für absolute Kacknoobs.
Leute, die ein bisschen gescheit sind,
die bestellen direkt in China das, was sie brauchen.
Leute, die einfach nur Noobs sind, bestellen bei Amazon.
Und Kacknoobs, die meinen, dass sie schlau wären,
die bestellen bei Wish.
Max, weißt du, wo man besten die Software für den ESP32 bekommt?
Welche denn?
Du meinst Huge Subscription?
Klar, das sage ich bei jedem, aber trotzdem danke für den Sub.
Na gut, immerhin.
Also wenn es 2 Terabyte sind,
dann haben die auch noch gefaked, mit was sich der USB-Stick meldet.
Ne, das überhitzt nicht, das Zeug ist so lahm,
das wird kaum Wärme generieren.
Siehste, war schon gar nicht so schlecht, Leute.
Ach so, um das WLED drauf zu flashen.
WLED, kannst du, das steht bei denen im Wiki, einfach ESP-Tool.
Einfach ESP-Tool nehmen.
ESP-Tool ist das offizielle Flash-Ding.
Guck mal bei denen im Wiki, die haben da eine Anleitung für.
ESP-Tool brauchst du.
Das ist schon fail.
Das ist schon echt richtiger Wish-Crap halt.
Hoho.
Ich sprühe mal kurz vor, du musst mir das Ding nochmal angucken.
Alter, dieses Ding, diese Konstruktion, das ist ja so kaputt.
Also das Ding, sowas, das können sich echt nur die Chinesen ausdenken.
Auf diese Idee, sowas zu bauen, da kannst du auch nicht blöde sein.
Da musst du schon das richtige Hirn dafür haben.
Weil alle anderen kommen gar nicht auf die Idee, sowas zu bauen.
Und wenn sie auf die Idee kommen, sagen sie, ey, sowas können wir doch nicht verkaufen.
Aber die haben damit keine Probleme.
Das Ding ist wirklich, das Ding ist echt...
Kann man, kann man Wish kontaktieren? Ich habe ja noch nie bei Wish bestellt.
Haben die sowas wie einen Support? Gibt es das überhaupt?
Oder ist einmal Scam-Pech?
Keine gibt es nicht.
Ey, AliExpress hat gar keinen so schlechten Support.
Deswegen hätte er sein können.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, das war ein lustiges Video.
Ja, gut. Übelster Craft, Alter. Aber nice das Video. Übelster Craft.
Gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile, wo wir gerade dabei sind, gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile 4TB M2 SSDs von Samsung?
Haben die es jetzt mittlerweile geschafft? Nö.
Die wollen einfach nicht, dass ich mir eine neue SSD kaufe, die Jungs von Samsung.
Ne, Max, gibt es nicht.
Und dabei haben die mittlerweile sogar schon bei SATA 8TB.
Was macht man jetzt damit, Electroshot? Ja, im Prinzip schon.
Man kann ja nichts mit anfangen.
AliExpress größer, was? AliExpress Support größer Paypal Support.
Ja, habe ich ja schon oft genug erzählt, die Sache.
Also finde ich echt.
Kurz durch scrollen, ob ich nicht was im Chat übersehen habe.
Ne, komm, ein eigenes Video gucken wir noch.
Das können wir uns mal angucken.
Wir können uns noch einen Battlefield Topplay angucken.
Irgendwelche Programmierdinger.
Weiß nicht, warum ich das aufhab.
Irgendeiner, der sich über VPNs auslässt, aber dazu habe ich mich ja auch schon ausgelassen.
Samsung, ne, das ist aber die, das ist die, das ist nicht die von Samsung, die ich holen will.
Ich weiß, dass es die gibt, die gibt es auch schon ein bisschen länger.
Also, weiß ich wie lange genau.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht irgendwie ein halbes Jahr höchstens.
Aber ich will so eine ganz normale Evo haben, wenn es die dann mal irgendwann gibt.
Kann man die Windows-Platte voll verschlüsseln?
Klar, guck da.
Windows-Platte voll verschlüsselt.
Komm, wir hören uns jetzt noch mal kurz an, was der zu VPNs sagt.
Ihr kennt ja mein, ihr kennt ja vielleicht, vielleicht mein Video zu VPNs.
Was tatsächlich ganz gut angekommen ist.
Und mal gucken was, mal gucken was er sagt.
Im Nachhinein kannst du das machen.
Serious Marks VeraCrypt installieren und dann einfach den Assistent durchklicken.
Das ist nicht schwierig.
Der macht dann auch einen Test vorher, ob alles funktioniert.
Warum VeraCrypt nicht Bitlocker?
Weil ich mal ganz am Anfang, als das neu war mit Bitlocker,
da gab es so eine News, dass Microsoft irgendwie Keys to Recoveren kann.
Und wie ich mich im letzten Stream lange genug ausgelassen habe darüber,
eine Verschlüsselung, wo man Passwörter und Daten wieder herstellen kann,
kann keine richtige Verschlüsselung sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da wirklich was dran war,
aber nachdem ich auch schon Jahre vorher TrueCrypt verwendet habe
und VeraCrypt quasi der TrueCrypt Nachfolger ist, bin ich da einfach beigeblieben.
Und er hat mich mit Bitlocker gar nicht großartig beschäftigt.
Aber ich meine, wozu auch?
Wozu auch, ne?
Das, VeraCrypt macht das alles und ist auch schön schnell.
Gerade wenn man eine CPU hat mit Hardware, Krypto-Sachen,
was fast jede CPU heutzutage ist.
Was geht?
ExpressVPN!
Oh NordVPN!
Die haben ich übrigens letztens auch angeschrieben.
Aber nicht NordVPN, sondern, ich guck mal kurz, welcher das war.
Surfshark!
Surfshark war es.
Surfshark hat mich letztens angeschrieben.
Das ist nur mit der super ultra generic Mail.
Surfshark.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie die Seite aussieht von dem Surfshark.
Okay, sieht aus wie jede 0815 VPN-Seite.
Habt ihr eine Erklärung dafür, warum seit so ein, zwei Jahren VPNs
so extrem boomen?
Das gab es ja vorher auch schon.
Da hat er recht.
Das ist eine Aussage, die kann ich unterschreiben.
Das ist richtig.
Außer natürlich mein Video.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das, was ich da ein bisschen blöd bei finde, ist,
ich erwarte gar nicht mal so sehr, dass die YouTube-Leute,
die da für Werbung machen, Ahnung haben.
Aber was halt ein bisschen doof ist, die lesen dann eins zu eins
diesen Werbetext vor von dem Hersteller, der sonst was verspricht,
wo halt schon echt vieles an den Haaren herbeigezogen ist.
Ich hab mich ja da im Video drüber ausgelassen und...
Ich find's immer gut, wie der Bauer Video-Sponsorings macht.
Der nimmt sich dann immer irgendwie für den Werbezettel von denen,
und erzählt dann irgendwie sowas, ja, das ist hier das neue Hardware
sowieso hier, und damit könnt ihr das und das machen,
und das ist das beste Produkt in dieser Richtung.
Und der Hersteller sagt auch, das ist ganz toll,
und ja, 580.000 Milliarden FPS und RGB, und weiter geht's.
Bestes Placement immer.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was er erzählt,
ob sich das so ungefähr in die gleiche Kerbe schlägt
mit dem, was ich erzählt hab.
Ja, aber, wie gesagt, wahrscheinlich sagt er das jetzt auch gleich noch,
aber das bedeutet nicht, dass die Verschlüsselung von dir
bis zu deinem Zielserver geht.
Das ist ja das, wo die Anbieter immer so tun.
Ich lass mich jetzt auch gar nicht so sehr aus,
wenn ihr es genau wissen wollt, guckt mal Video an.
Die Verschlüsselung geht nur von euch bis zum VPN-Anbieter.
Und wenn ihr danach eine Seite aufmacht, die nicht HTTPS ist
oder nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise den Payload verschlüsselt,
ist das hier Klartext lesbar, obwohl ihr einen VPN habt.
Also sprich, das VPN macht eigentlich die Sache nicht sicherer in dem Sinn.
HTTPS in 2K20 in 2020, ja, hast du schon recht.
Ja, aber er hat recht hier im Video.
Magenta VPN.
Bring die Telekom nicht auf die Idee.
Alter, Magenta VPN, wenn ich das schon hör, das könnte exakt so...
Genau so ein Produkt von der Telekom könnt ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Ich mein, die machen mal Game Streaming mit.
Die haben den Magenta Thursday, wo Amazon den Black Friday hat.
Die haben die eigene Magenta Cloud.
Da musste mal der Microsoft-Schulungsmensch,
der musste mal wirklich kecken, als ich ihn das gefragt hab.
Der hat erzählt, ja, wenn man die Sachen in Azure macht,
man hat ja da auch Interop-Möglichkeiten mit anderen Cloud-Plattformen,
sei es jetzt irgendwie AWS oder Google oder sonst wie.
Da hab ich ihn gefragt, ja, und, wie sieht das mit der Magenta Cloud aus?
Dann hat er erst mal so geguckt und hat dann irgendwie so was gesagt,
ja, er meint richtige Cloud-Lösung.
Ich kann dazu übrigens nicht sagen, vielleicht ist die auch ganz okay.
Ja, das kann man nicht...
Das ist vollkommen richtig, was er sagt.
Ich muss mal kurz anhören, weil dafür ist es wirklich sinnvoll.
Genau, wenn du im Hotel bist oder so, dann ist das sinnvoll.
Wobei man das auch mit einem VPN daheim machen kann.
Ah, aha, OTC ist Open Telecom Cloud.
Hauptsache eine Abkürzung für...
Das stimmt, das ist richtig.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Es ist wirklich selten mittlerweile bei größeren Seiten,
dass du da auf unverschlüsseltes HTTP kommst, ja.
Ich meine, sogar mein Zeug hat alles mittlerweile HTTPS.
Sogar intern.
Dank Cloudflare DNS.
Kannst du HTML?
Rusty, du bist doch jetzt schon längere Zeit im Stream, oder?
Und wir haben doch sogar schon komplette Web-Anwendungen hier gebastelt.
Also ja, ich kann HTML.
Sofern man davon können sprechen kann.
Ich kann ein paar Texts schreiben und ich kann ekliges Design dabei machen,
aber ja, ich kicke so weit hin.
Nee, der Gamer Alex, das mache ich nicht.
Das lasse ich bei unseren Azubis auch immer gelten.
Wenn die sagen, ich kann HTML programmieren,
ich mache nie den Klugscheißer mit von wegen.
HTML ist keine Programmiersprache.
CSS ist ja genau genommen auch keine Programmiersprache, ja.
Wobei ich halt sagen muss, dass sowohl HTML als auch CSS
mittlerweile schon eine gewisse Komplexität haben.
Klar, du hast da keine Kontrollsachen, du kannst keine IF machen,
du kannst keine Schleife machen, du kannst keine Jumps machen und so was.
Aber es hat alles eine gewisse Komplexität
und man schreibt Source Code und es kommt am Ende was raus.
Das geht bei mir als Programmiersprache durch.
Oh, ich muss ins Bett.
Ja, aber er hat Recht.
Ja, in dem Fall lohnt sich das wirklich nicht.
In dem Fall lohnt sich das wirklich nicht, genau.
Im Prinzip sagt das gleiche, wie ich auch gesagt habe.
Ja, dafür ist es tatsächlich sinnvoll,
wenn man beispielsweise Netflix gucken will in einem anderen Land
und wo Sachen gesperrt sind, so ja, dafür kann man das schon verwenden.
Ja, das braucht man nicht.
Genau, genau, ja, das ist das, was ich gemeint habe.
Damit sind aber auch alle Vorteile schon von VPN,
wie es die Anbieter da erzählen, ausgeschöppt.
Also mehr Vorteile gibt es nicht.
Die zwei Sachen sind es.
Beöffentlichtes WLAN und umgeplogte Sachen zu verwenden.
Oder ein drittes noch, falls einer irgendwelche Torrensachen laden will oder so.
Oder halt irgendwelche illegalen Dinger machen.
Dann vielleicht, ja.
Wobei ich bei illegalen Dingern, ich meine,
ich spreche nicht aus Erfahrung, muss ich nochmal dazu sagen.
Da würde ich eher Tor verwenden.
Aber für Downloads und generell große Bandbreite bei Tors sackt natürlich ein bisschen.
Aber wenn man Torrens macht, mit dem man sich natürlich nur Linux-Distributionen
oder Sicherheitskopien runterlädt,
dann kann nichts passieren.
Kupa, du hast mir nicht zugehört.
Ich habe gesagt, du sollst es nicht verwenden dafür.
Ja, das stimmt.
Void Danny, das ist eine gute Frage.
Er sagt, dein Provider kann die angefragten Ressourcen noch mitlesen, oder?
Das kommt drauf an. Wenn es HTTPS ist, dann nicht.
Wenn es unverschlüsselt ist, ja.
Ja, aber auch nur zum Teil.
Aber auch nur zum Teil.
Wenn du das mit einem Browser Fingerprint oder sowas machst, habe ich ja auch in meinem Video erzählt.
Mittlerweile sind so Fingerprinting-Geschichten recht advanced.
Mit wie schnell malt man auf einem Canvas, wie sieht ein Emoji aus und sowas.
Da kriegt man relativ mit Trick 17 raus, wer das ist.
So würde ich es auch machen.
Ja, VPN mit Tor zusammen muss nicht sein.
Nee, das würde ich auch nicht machen.
Also wie gesagt, wenn ich irgendwelche komischen Dinge machen möchte im Internet oder machen würde im Internet,
dann über Tor.
Und wenn ich Linux-Distributionen über Tor an drunter laden will, dann kann man das über ein VPN machen,
weil höhere Bandbreite über Tor ist nicht so geil.
Ach ja, und das mit DNS ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Genau so ist es.
Das habe ich in meinem Video auch gesagt.
Nur weil der Anbieter sagt, er macht nichts.
Google sagt auch, sie machen nichts, Google sagt das auch.
Sogar der Zuck sagt das, dass er nichts macht in der Richtung.
Also sprich, warum sollte man so einem VPN-Anbieter mehr vertrauen?
Und die Frage ist halt auch, wenn, Zuck, genau, genau, wenn bei dem VPN-Anbieter mal die Polizei auf der Matte steht,
ist halt die Frage, wie kooperativ sie dann sind.
Ja gut, Lorenzo Dabba, dann bist du ja der Admin.
Ja, das ist sicherer.
Wobei natürlich die Leute im Rechenzentrum potenziell immer noch Zugriff drauf haben.
Also wenn du wirklich irgendwelche Dinge machst, die nicht legal sind,
was ich hier nochmal, wie gesagt, keinem irgendwie empfehle.
Also nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie Anzeige ist raus oder so.
Also die Polizei steht im RZ und konfestiert deinen Server, da hast du auch gelitten.
Da kannst du noch verschlüsseln.
Ja, es ist generell gar nicht so einfach, komplett anonym zu sein.
Man weiß es nicht, ja.
Stimmt.
Da hat er recht.
Ich glaube, das habe ich in meinem Video gar nicht erwähnt.
Dass es ja auch eine Sache ist, ob man anonym bezahlen kann oder nicht.
Ja, Clocks HD wundert mich nicht, die sind ja auch nicht blöd.
Da hat er nicht unrecht.
Im Prinzip sagt er genau das gleiche wie ich.
Plus das mit dem Bezahlen, das habe ich glaube ich in meinem Video gar nicht dran gedacht.
Du weißt ja auch, warum es dieses WebRTC League gibt.
Zumindest, was ich vermute, wirklich im Detail habe ich mir das nicht angeschaut,
weil WebRTC eine Verbindung aufbaut, Peer-to-Peer.
Und die müssen quasi Kandidaten austauschen, sprich unter welchen Adressen die jeweiligen Pairs erreichbar sind,
dass man auch mal beispielsweise über einen Nutt rauskommt.
Also sprich, wenn der hinter einem Nutt ist und der kleine hinter einem Nutt ist,
Und dann hast du hier einen Signaling-Server, aber die Clients müssen ja untereinander kommunizieren.
Und die tauschen dann halt IP-Adresskandidaten aus und wenn die was gefunden haben, was zusammenfunktioniert wird, wird's verwendet.
Das Ganze muss halt auch über NAT-Grenzen hinweggehen, weil die Leute halt gewöhnlich daheim hinter irgendeinem Router sitzen, vielleicht noch IPv4.
Und das heißt, das muss irgendwas austauschen.
Ja, und diese WebRTC-Leak an sich habe ich mir nicht angeguckt, aber ich stelle mir es halt vor, dass es gar nicht anders geht.
Was ist WebRTC? Das ist ein Protokoll zum möglichst latency-freien Austausch von Audio-Video.
Also sprich, wenn du mit anderen Leuten Videokonferenz machst oder so.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass mittlerweile Discord und Teams auch über WebRTC gehen.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich könnte es mir gut vorstellen.
Also meine Überwachungskamera-App geht über WebRTC, die wir hier schon ein bisschen gebastelt haben.
Da hat er recht.
Okay, jetzt kommt Browser-Fingerprinting. Was kommt danach noch?
Ne, das war's.
Also man kann, das habe ich auch bei mir im Video gesagt, wenn man guckt, gerade diese Canvas-Sachen sind sehr beliebt.
Also, da muss ich jetzt vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen ausholen.
Also, wenn ihr euch vorstellt, ihr benutzt einen VPN.
Das heißt, die Gegenseite kann euch ja nicht wirklich anhand der IP-Adresse irgendwie erkennen.
Normalerweise verwendet ihr euren Rechner daheim mit immer der gleichen IP.
Also Internetzugang daheim, Rechner-IP ist egal.
Aber ihr habt immer die gleiche Ausgangs-IP daheim, weil Unity Media nur gefühlt alle frag mich nicht 5 Monate machen, refresht.
Und da kann euch der Anbieter relativ gut anhand der IP erkennen, ob ihr das seid.
So, jetzt verwendet ihr einen VPN.
Das heißt, der Anbieter kann euch schon mal nicht anhand eurer IP-Adresse erkennen.
Aber das muss der auch gar nicht.
Weil es gibt ziemlich viele Tricks und das ist ein Teil von dem, was er hier zeigt.
Es gibt ziemlich viele Tricks, wie man rausfinden kann, welcher Benutzer was ist.
Zum Beispiel kann man, unabhängig jetzt mal hier von der IP, man kann sowas sagen,
was übrigens viele Browser nicht mehr rausrücken.
Aber mal angenommen, man hat die Kombination aus Browser-Versionen, Browser-Bild, Operating-System,
Schriftarten waren früher ganz beliebt, installierte Schriftarten.
Und wenn man das alles quasi so einen Hashtrauß bildet, wenn man sich anguckt,
wir haben jetzt so 15, 20 verschiedene Merkmale von diesem Browser,
dann sind die wahrscheinlich relativ einzigartig, zumindest für den Service.
Und was halt ziemlich beliebt ist, ist Canvas, über den Canvas zu machen.
Canvas ist bei HTML so was, wo ich quasi frei drauf malen kann als Website-Designer.
Zum Beispiel diese Overlays, wo der, was in welchem Video-Feed erkannt hat in diesem einen Programm,
was wir im Streamer gebaut haben, das ist mit einem Canvas gemacht.
Und da kannst du ganz abgedrehte Sachen machen.
Ich hab da mal einen Bericht, also so einen Blog-Eintrag drüber gelesen.
Du kannst zum Beispiel testen, wenn du feststellst, also der Browser rückt nicht mehr raus,
was er für Schriftarten hat, der Browser rückt nicht mehr raus, was er für einen Browser ist.
Aber du kannst beispielsweise einen Canvas nehmen und malst da mal einen Emoji drauf.
Schon weißt du, was der für ein Betriebssystem verwendet,
weil je nach Betriebssystem sehen die Emojis anders aus.
Du verwendest Mac, du hast die Mac-Style Emojis, du hast Windows, du hast die Windows-Style Emojis.
Wenn du einen Canvas nimmst und Emoji drauf malst, kannst du danach einfach gucken,
wie das Emoji aussieht und weißt ziemlich gut, was das für ein Betriebssystem ist,
ob es Android, iOS ist, sonst was in der Richtung.
Dann kannst du noch machen, also wie gesagt, ich hab da selbst jetzt die Wahnsinnserfahrung mit,
ich hab da mal mich ein bisschen drüber schlau gemacht vor einer Weile.
Dann kannst du zum Beispiel noch Zeit messen, du kannst gucken, wie lang dauern gewisse Sachen,
dann kannst du dir so ungefähr gucken, welche Performance der Rechner hat.
Und gerade das in Kombination mit den anderen Sachen, wenn ich das habe, sprich,
wie lang braucht das gewisse Sachen zu machen,
dann in Kombination mit den restlichen Merkmalen, ist das ein ziemlich eindeutiger Indikator,
unabhängig von der IP-Adresse, welcher Benutzer was ist, an welchem Rechner und mit welchem Browser.
Hört sich sehr interessant an, wie malt man denn was?
Du machst einfach ein Canvas-Element, das ist eigentlich ziemlich easy.
Du machst ein Canvas-Element und dann kannst du mit Javascript da drauf malen.
Dann kannst du ja hier, genau, so malst du was.
Du machst ein Canvas-Element, HTML und Javascript kannst du dann so was hier sagen.
Move zu 00, 00 ist die linke obere Ecke, mal eine Linie zu diesen Koordinaten,
das ist dann da und, ne, das stimmt übrigens nicht, was ich gesagt habe,
schieb den Maus-Cursor, nennen wir es mal Maus-Cursor, ja, in die linke obere Ecke,
dann schieb ihn dahin und jetzt mal zwischen den beiden Punkten eine Linie.
Kannst du malen.
Darüber kann man doch nicht den Standort rausfinden.
Nein, den Standort kannst du da drüber nicht rausfinden, das stimmt.
Aber wenn du eine Seite öfters auch von deinem normalen Browser aus verwendest
und die machen hier einen guten Fingerprint von deinem Browser
und dann gehst du da per Tor drauf oder per VPN,
dann können die ja trotzdem feststellen, dass du das bist und gucken einfach,
ok, von welchen IPs hat er sich eingeloggt,
ah, zu 90% loggt er sich aus Frankfurt, Deutschland ein, da wird er wohl wohnen.
Ok, das Video müssen wir uns jetzt nicht fertig angucken.
Der sagt im Prinzip das gleiche.
Und Bob Ross malt auch aufs Canvas, ja.
Aber der Gamer Alex, das ist jetzt,
wie gesagt Canvas ist ganz normale HTML Geschichte,
also so 0815 HTML Kram kann man auf jeder Webseite machen,
ist nichts krasses Hacker Zeug,
aber mit einem Canvas rausbekommen, welcher User es ist,
das ist schon ein bisschen komplizierter.
Tja, so Leute, eigentlich wollte ich jetzt ins Bett,
wollen wir noch, wollen wir noch das Battlefield Video gucken
oder wollen wir uns am Sonntag angucken?
Können sie sich überlegen, gucken wir noch Battlefield?
Aber wir gucken noch Battlefield, oder?
Wir gucken noch Battlefield.
Alles lustig ohne Battlefield zu gucken.
Exzellent.
Sonntag.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Heute.
Wir gucken einfach heute das und am Sonntag gucken wir noch eins.
Der hat ja genug.
Aber endlich mal einer mit einer gescheiten Auflösung.
Endlich mal einer mit einer gescheiten Auflösung, ey.
Beste übrigens hier, die Stelle,
eine der besten Defender oder generell besten Posis im ganzen Game.
Genau, genau, Moment, haben wir das nicht schon gesehen?
Kennen wir das nicht schon?
Links war, glaube ich, ein Teammate.
Kennen wir das?
Nee, das hat er hochgeladen.
Heute, das können wir nicht kennen.
Hast du einen 4K-Screen? Nee.
Alter, wie sie sich wegspringen lassen.
Aber die Pose ist auch extrem geil.
Was ich da schon für Kills gemacht habe.
Alter, was ist mit denen los? Guckt es euch an.
Oh.
Hätte ich diesen Clip gebracht,
hätten mich die Leute schon angeschissen,
als ich den Typ hinter mir nicht wiederbelebt hätte.
Machst du eigentlich mal ein Setup-Video?
Ja, wenn ich eine Möglichkeit gefunden habe,
da ich nicht zu viel liege, schon.
Bäm, Rex, beste.
Beste Pistol, Porgers.
Ja, falsche, falsche.
Emote.
Beste Pistol, Rex.
Bam, bababam, bababam, oh.
Bis es sowieso liegt,
weil ich mich im Tablet gespiegelt habe, oder was?
Bam, in den Kopf.
Diese Pose, ich hasse Leute, die da oben rum gammeln.
Zum Glück gammelt er nicht lange rum.
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ist das...
Ist das TDM?
Ist das, ist das TDM?
Warum stehen die mit Mörsern im TDM da rum?
Was ist denn, was ist mit denen los?
Manu Zorsch, was ist da los?
Warum stehen die mit Mörsern in der Ecke?
In TDM?
Das Game hat keine Bots.
Aber der ist wahrscheinlich auf ähnlichem Niveau wie ein Bot, ja.
Das war kein 360 vorher, ist nicht approved.
Bam, zack, jawoll.
Ah.
Das ist ja auch meine persönliche Lieblingswaffe in dem Game.
Oh, wie sie es nicht mitkriegen, ey.
Aber hell, viel Drei kann so viel Bock machen.
Ohje, ich ahne Schlimmes.
Wie langsam reagieren tun die Gegner bitteschön, was ist das denn hier?
Absolut pepega, pepega Gegner auf Doom, Alter, was ist das?
Wie wäre es, wenn da mal einer auf ihn schießt?
Vielleicht Noob-Server, aber es gibt keine Noob.
Eigentlich dürfte es in diesem Game keine Noobs geben, das ist 10 Jahre alt.
Oder 9 Jahre, oder 10 Jahre alt auf jeden Fall.
Oder 8 Jahre, 8 Jahre ist es glaube ich erst.
Boah, ich komme mit dem Ding nicht klar.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein neues Gameplay ist, dass es die Twitch Noobs sind.
Ich wollte es eigentlich spielen jetzt die Tage noch mal, weil halt Twitch Noobs am
Start sind.
Die genau, die spielen auf Android, so sieht es echt aus.
Außer ihm spielen sie alle auf dem Tablet.
Anleitung, dass die jetzt wieder 3 Stunden brauchen, der hat ewig im Gang rum gestanden.
Also Kitswitchen hat in Bad Company 2 am besten funktioniert fand ich und am meisten Bock
gemacht.
WF3 hat es ein bisschen länger gedauert, habe ich zumindest den Eindruck, dass es aufgehoben
hat.
Generell war Bad Company 2 eh ein bisschen schwerfälliger, deswegen war das cool mit
dem Zack, Kitswitchen, weiterballern, Kitswitchen.
Oh, wie sie sich wegsprayen lassen, Alter.
So muss das sein, ne.
Da liegt bestimmt noch irgend, ja irgend so ein planloser Schneiper, Dude, was sonst?
Ich hab Urlaub bis Januar, ja.
Ich weiß, ich weiß genau Leute, hätte ich dieses Gameplay gebracht, hätte ich dieses
Gameplay gebracht, dann hätte an dieser Stelle jetzt irgendeiner, irgendwie einer was in
der Richtung geschrieben wie, Max also das Gameplay ist aber ganz gut, aber du könntest
auch mal ab und zu wieder beleben.
Warum belebst du nie deine Teammates wieder?
Weil 50 Milliarden Gegner vor mir stehen.
Zack, immer, immer, der Typ steht immer auf dieser Pose, immer, alle Clips, die wir bisher
von dem gesehen haben, der steht immer Caspian Board, immer, also wirklich, ich hab den noch
nie in anderen Clips gesehen, immer an dieser Ecke.
Ich mein, das ist ein geiler Schuss, aber der macht den ganzen Tag nix anders.
Das sind so Sachen, das sind so Typen, die fucken mich immer richtig ab, weil die überhaupt
nichts zur Runde beitragen, am Arsch der Welt rumstehen und zwei Kills die Runde machen,
aber dafür nice kill.
Ich hab noch nicht mal gesehen, wo der Gegner ist überhaupt, guck doch schon den Hintergrund
an ey.
Ach, enemy Helikopter, bam, in your ass, ah, yes, ein A-Cog, spielt ihr eher A-Cog oder
A-Cog, sag mal, was ist denn, was ist mit dem da los, was ist hier los, ihr hört den
Typ daneben schießen oder, hier von links hört man den Typ schießen, also was ist mit
dem los, hat er wirklich jetzt 20 mal vorbei geschossen bei einem, der hoch die Treppe
gelaufen ist, ey, ich werd auch gern so Gegner, passt mal auf, wisst ihr was, ich predikte
jetzt mal was, nächstes Battlefield kommt raus, ist ganz gut, aber hat Skill-Based-Banch-Making,
ich kanns mir richtig vorstellen, oh nice, was ist mit dem Typ da, was macht der da,
was, was, was hat der LMG, was hat diese LMG Dude da gerade versucht, der steht hinter
der Kiste, da ist nix, Skill-Based-Banch-Making ist gut in dem Ranked-Modus, nicht in dem
Quickplay-Modus, in Quickplay ist es scheiße, im Ranked ist es essentiell wichtig, die Leute
die dagegen sind, die sind ja eher dagegen, dass es in Quickplay drinne ist, ich find
es übrigens auch kacke, im Ranked muss das natürlich sein, zack, oh das fucked up, schon
wieder der Kerl, den hatten wir schon in jedem Video gefühlt, das dauert ein bisschen länger
als da steht, oh ja das hab ich auch immer neid, das beste ohne scheiß an dieser Granatwerfer
ist die beste Waffe im Game, das Ding ist so brutal, wenn du da einen Haufen Gegner findest,
fliegen auf einmal 8 Stück in die Luft, vor allem weil man nachladen kann, während man
auf dem LMG ist, alter was ist, oh guckt euch an, lul, alter, wie sie reingerannt sind,
du kannst ja gar keine klaren Worte mehr aussprechen, die Teammates, und hat der denn Glück, der
hat so ne riesen Glück, dass hinter ihm da grad keiner hochkommt, oh man, pepega Gegner
keine Augen, keine Ohren, das ist wirklich taubstumme blinde Gegner, keine Hände kommt
auch noch dabei, oh nice, und kommt er noch rein, kommt er noch rein, oh boah, er kommt
sogar noch in die Zone rein, moment, der hat ne G8, der Gegner hatte ne G18 Singelschuss,
wer verwendet denn so nen Crap, oder G17C war das glaub ich, wie sie sich wegholzen
lassen ey, jetzt ist er down, was comrade ist das, das ist etwa comrade,
das ist wieder der Typ im Unterhemd, den hatten wir auch schon ein paar mal, der wird
danach definitiv geflammt, Shotgun Gameplay muss geflammt werden, was ist denn das für
ne Range, guck dir das mal an, Rammertv, kann sich noch einer an M26 start erinnern, M26
start, Shotgun across the map, one hit, das war so grass OP das Ding, vor allem der Sound,
der Sound von der M26 start, der war ja auch so richtig harmlos eigentlich so, bock, hat
das ja nur gemacht, bock, tk tk, das hat sich überhaupt nicht wuchtig angehört, hat
across the map one shotted, mp, nee pp-19, ich seh pp-19 war die base game oder dlc, ich
kann mich dort noch mehr dran erinnern, dlc, base game, ja war es jetzt chat, dlc, ich
spiele nämlich auch an das dlc war, excellent, nice video, die plays sind immer cool, das
commentary kann man knicken aber, ja, ok leute, 22.40 bemüht, ich geh ins Bett, wir sehen
uns morgen, dann hoffentlich wieder mit nem, relativ früh wahrscheinlich, mit nem bisschen
programmier stream, wir müssen das zeug endlich mal weitermachen und wir sehen uns dann,
bis morgen, machts gut, see you.